let's go back to the phones and see
what's on people's minds a lot of the
phones are happened today let's go to
our caller from the 267 area code caller
from 267 please introduce yourself tell
us where you're calling from and what's
on your mind today um hello yeah that's
you 267 who's this okay yeah this is uh
so um just want to say it you know we
talked about you know the benefits of
you know health care you know free
health care free school and free
whatever and they always ask a question
well how they gonna pay for this
yeah and I was someone that sent me a
notice about how all all the great
benefits of being in Congress you know
besides a pension and all and protection
you know lifetime protection whatnot but
also free college free health care and
all these things that that somehow when
we have it's too expensive it's how they
being paid for by us yeah now that
should be raised awareness why don't we
raise awareness about that oh let me see
if I understand what you're what if I
understand what you're saying Philly
when people say how can we afford and
pay for free health care or all this
other stuff we say we're already doing
it for all of our members of Congress
why why can't we do it for everybody is
that sort of what you're saying yes I
think it's interesting I mean I think
the obvious rebuttal would be doing it
for 535 people is different than doing
it for 340 million or how you know
obviously it wouldn't be a full 340
million but I like the way you're
thinking because there are actually lots
of much better answers to is often when
people say how are we gonna pay for it
we go into well we would pay for it with
a 2.7 percent payroll tax according to
Bernie's plan but they're like we
immediately get muddled and I think that
there are lots of simpler answers one
being we're already paying for it just
in other ways right
so I think that that's that's like an
obvious low-hanging fruit I don't know
about the we're already paying for it
from for Congress that might be more of
a moral argument but I don't know that
it's the best economic argument okay
well I was thinking that how they are
leaders in these examples for everyone
else that Oh what so I think that that's
actually interesting which is
if it's so morally wrong to have
government pay for your healthcare or
whatever why is it that the 535 elected
leaders of this country are getting that
stuff that actually I feel is stronger I
like that more Phil yeah well keep up
the good work thank you very much okay
thank you appreciate you calling in yeah
that's it I was kind of swayed a little
bit I still think you have to deal with
the economic part yeah but from from it
is an interesting moral argument
remember Ted Cruz around the time that
Obamacare was being debated he said
something like I actually don't have
health insurance right now yeah and he
was offered it because he's a senator
after all but he wanted to make a point
yeah that ad ACA is just going to hurt
all of us so it's just grandstanding at
the end of it a lot of grandstanding I
completely agree with you